welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and today we're
going to start down some chili dogs and
break down everything that happened in
sonic 2. this sequel was a hilarious
adorable follow-up to the first film and
a pretty solid example of how to adapt a
video game into a movie with respect and
loyalty to the source material sonic 2
is filled with tons of missable details
and even a few hints at where the story
will take us in the next movie there's
never been more streaming content
available but it's hard to find the
streaming content you actually want to
watch that's where likewise comes in
likewise just launched likewise tv a
personalized streaming hub that
simplifies finding what you want to
watch by aggregating content from all
your streaming services into one
convenient place based on your
preferences likewise tv offers
personalized recommendations to fit your
tastes you're not just being fed the
latest releases or the streaming
services top 10 but you're seeing the
deeper cuts and hidden gems i can save
any show or movie that i'm interested in
and it appears on my likewise tv watch
list a single cross service watch list
for all of my streaming services when
i'm ready to watch something likewise tv
conveniently launches the show or movie
regardless of streaming service with
just one click using their watch now
feature i get notified when new seasons
of my favorite shows are available or
when a movie i love is about to leave a
streaming service i have likewise tv
makes it easy to share recommendations
directly with friends and family and to
see their recommendations too i love how
efficient it makes finding what i want
to watch if i want to watch some jason
bourne pungent people content it tells
me that born ultimatum is on netflix but
born supremacy is over on hbo max try
likewise tv today click the link in the
video's description so that they know we
sent you and rings your streaming game
with likewise tv let's speed into it the
opening scene shows the mushroom planet
where dr robotnik was banished at the
end of the first film jim carrey's back
baby and his mustache has only gotten
bigger and more ridiculous
the fungi-covered terrain of this planet
is directly inspired by the first zone
from sonic and knuckles sega's 1994
continuation of sonic the hedgehog 3.
sonic and tails see knuckles leaving the
mushroom hill zone through a hidden
passageway on their quest to find
robotnik and put a stop to his ultimate
goal of rebuilding the death egg it
turns out that eggman has been spending
his time away building intricate rube
goldberg machines out of mushrooms in an
attempt to make coffee that tastes good
there's even a little boulder with
robotnik's logo carved into it that
chases his miniature sonic figure down a
slow indiana jones style before crushing
little sonic and the mushrooms into tea
he's also made himself a castaway style
friend allah wilson named stone after
his assistant and even created a chess
set to play with himself entirely out of
shrooms if you listen closely to
robotnik when the other aliens first
appear through the portal he says clattu
bharatanyto the classic alien language
phrase from 1951's the day the earth
stood still written by edmund h north
and is widely considered the most famous
extraterrestrial command in science
fiction good
in the movie army of darkness ash
attempts to say this phrase as an
incantation to help him return home
after accidentally being transported
back in time
[Music]
and here robotnik says it as he's trying
to return to earth after his banishment
before he can leave knuckles walks
through the portal idris elba actually
said in interviews that he wasn't gonna
give knuckles a sexy voice but clearly
he did not stay true to his work now
let's begin our quest back in seattle
the most adorable pug i've ever seen
besides my dog pugsley is one of the
many witnesses to a fast and furious
police chase as sonic patrols the city
like a crime-fighting vigilante from
above it's tricky by run dmc begins to
play before sonic sets out to thwart
some armored van hijackers he gets in
some stretches that are reminiscent of
his stretching animations throughout the
games he also takes a big bite out of a
chili dog his signature favorite treat
as established in the 1993 adventures of
sonic the hedgehog animated series as
sonic barrels down the street in an out
of control van he dubs himself blue
justice a reference to batman and says
that he's the hero you need and the hero
you deserve similar dark knight not the
hero
we're deserved with the hero we needed
shots from sonic's opening scene are
very reminiscent of the beginning scenes
to 1998's sonic adventures down to sonic
overseeing a police chase from a
high-rise perch one of the most telling
shots is this eruption of water
throughout the city manholes while
tchaikovsky's 1812 overture plays in the
background this scene is taken from
sonic avengers intro cut scene and
teases the presence of chaos a monstrous
water-like god of destruction we haven't
seen chaos pop up in this film series
but my guess is that this hints at his
possible appearance in future sequels
after the man disassembles and screeches
to a halt a car door lands on top of one
of the thieves and the framing of it
around his body makes it look like he's
trapped inside a game boy this shot of
sonic posing in front of the moon
reminds me of the intro cinematics of
shadow the hedgehog in his 2005
shoot-'em-up solo spin-off teasing
shadow's appearance in the post-credits
scene but we'll talk more about this guy
later back at the wakowski home in green
hills a nod to the green hill zone in
the first level of the original game
sonic returns from his all-nighter
jonesing for a nap in his race car bed
pulled straight from the archie comics
sonic the hedgehog run but it turns out
that tom discovered his cover story a
ferris bueller-esque heart attack
simulator and the jig is up the decoy
that sonic uses is a subtle joke about
bad sonic designs and of course the
cause of the farts is none other than
sonic's favorite food from the games
chili dogs he reminds sonic that he's
still a kid and tells him that he's
gotta stop acting like batman reign in
his recklessness and let the opportunity
to be a hero come to him if you recall
from the first movie sonic was actually
a huge fan of another dc comics hero
fellow speedster the flash tom and
maddie use one of sonic's rings to open
a portal to hawaii where maddie's sister
rachel is getting married to a man named
randall at the four seasons as soon as
they leave sonic goes full kevin
mcallister in home alone and starts
partying hard even practicing his
skateboard tricks in the wackowski home
you know like any good tubular mascot
created in the 90s would do if you look
closely at the board sonic is using it
has a similar design to concept art of
sonic skate and snowboards from sonic
adventures when tom calls to check in
sonic still has his dad saved as donut
lord in his phone as sonic browses for a
movie to watch he rejects the movie snow
dogs saying this movie is the
worst just like ben schwartz's character
jean-ralphio from parks and rec
fun fact voice actor roger craig smith
voiced sonic in a crossover episode with
cartoon network's okko and actually did
the john ralphio impersonation while
describing dr eggman he's the worst
so even though ben schwartz was the
first to say that phrase he wasn't
actually the first sonic to say it
unbeknownst to him both tales and
robotnik have just shown up in green
hills looking for him and sonic is
caught off guard by eggman and his new
pal knuckles his attack when the lights
go off and the tv switches to static
sonic says excuse me we did not order a
poltergeist referencing the scene from
1982's horror film of the same name
robotnik tells sonic and wikowski's pup
ozzy that he's gonna get him and his
little dog too quoting the wicked witch
from the wizard of oz knuckles explains
that he's the sole survivor of his race
the echidnas and that his people died in
a war against longclaw and the owl
warriors who raised sonic in his early
years luckily tails pulls up in a stolen
cop card just in time to save sonic from
clifford the big red rage monster tails
is voiced by colleen o'shaughnessy who
voiced the character in multiple games
as well as in the 2014 sonic boom
animated series tails tells sonic that
knuckles is after the master emerald and
then he must believe sonic knows how to
find it in the games the nearly extinct
echidna race were responsible for
bringing the chaos emeralds together to
form the master emerald the chaos
emeralds are essentially sonic's version
of the infinity stones and they can
bestow their users with massive power
the master emerald on the other hand is
considered even more powerful and acts
as a nullifier to uno reverse the chaos
emeralds if they were ever assembled for
nefarious purposes all of this
information was first introduced to us
in knuckles game debut in sonic the
hedgehog 3 and in that storyline
robotnik tricks knuckles into working
with him by making him believe that
sonic is trying to steal the gem over at
a coffee shop called the mean bean agent
stone has apparently decided to
capitalize on his making talents from
the first film the name of the shop is a
nod to the 1993 sega game dr robotnik's
mean bean machine agent stone also has
this super cute dr robotnik flower pot
on the mean bean countertop to help ease
the pain of his lost mentor and he's
playing everyone's favorite coffee shop
classic don't know why by norah jones
when we see him designing outfits for
his boss later on eggman's modern big
belly design is one of the options he's
alerted that robotnik has returned and
immediately fires the death egg from a
satellite in space robotnik's death egg
lands on earth and releases buzz bomber
drones which made their first debut in
sega genesis 1991 game we saw his new
bald look briefly in the last movie but
now we finally get to see robotnik don
eggman's signature red and black coat
with golden highlights after helping him
up and aggressively flossing in his
general direction eggman convinces
knuckles to help him get to the master
emerald before sonic finds it when
knuckles chases sonic down the highway
he crashes through a water truck that
says splash hill zone a nod to one of
the levels in sonic the hedgehog 4.
turns out that sonic does have a leg up
on his enemies however over at the wade
cave sonic realizes that the map that
longclaw left him has a giant image of
an emerald on it and when sonic touches
it the gem lights up and projects a
princess leia s hologram of longclaw
with one last message to her favorite
little hedgehog she confirms that if
he's seeing this message she's
definitely dead but tells sonic that he
can still protect the emerald from
falling into the wrong hands in her
absence as the guardian of the master
emerald the emerald is hidden somewhere
on earth and the user who wields its
power has the ability to turn thoughts
into ideas which wade whispers is just
like the stay puft marshmallow man from
ghostbusters she instructs sonic to
follow the map find the emerald and keep
it safe at all costs tails and sonic
portal off to siberia to find the
compass that will lead them to the
emerald where they seek shelter from a
blizzard in a bar full of tough guys
while using her device as a translator
you can see a set of numbers that read
11 21 92 which was the day sonic 2
released on the sega genesis back at the
mean bean robotnik has knuckles text
sonic pretending to be tom so that they
could find them the holographic image of
sonic that robotnik has looks like
sonic's idol animation from the games
when tails and sonic find themselves in
the middle of a bar fight to get their
map back there's only one thing that can
save them from being thrown into the
fireplace a dance battle sonic laments
that channing tatum makes it look so
easy so if you had magic mic mail strip
or humor in your bingo column for this
movie go ahead and mark off that square
as they dance fight and fly to bruno
mars uptown funk a song that definitely
has more than one reference to cocaine
in it it's true why are they putting
cocaine in a kid's movie it's like jesus
christ this is sonic what the [ __ ] sonic
busts a move that looks like the pose on
the cover art of sonic adventure
thankfully they win their map back and
set off towards an ice cave deep in the
mountains that has a giant owl door and
a giant owl statue inside tales gives
sonic the rundown on the history of
conflict between the echidnas and owls
telling him that the emerald was stolen
from the echidnas out of fear that they
would use it for ultimate power and
hidden away by longclaw and the owl
warriors in a secret location sonic
comments that the owl warriors in the
echidnas are beefin just like vin diesel
and the rock which is a reference to the
real life falling out that the two
actors had on the set of the fast and
the furious films the runes on the
statue are babylonian an homage to the
2006 game sonic writers that featured
the babylon rogues which makes me think
that we may see jet the hawk wave the
swallow and storm the albatross in a
future sonic movie the owl statue gives
sonic and tails the compass but robotnik
and knuckles show up in eggman's
eggmobile from the games as sonic
snowboards away from his foes the
landscape looks just like the ice cap
zone from sonic 3. while sonic first hit
the slopes in 94 sonic the hedgehog 3
this scene could be inspired from 2001
sonic adventure 2 where sonic repurposes
metal from a helicopter into a board to
flee from gun soldiers as sonic dodges
robotnik's laser drones on his snowboard
the song a summer place by andy williams
begins to play when knuckles catches up
to him on his own makeshift board sonic
sarcastically says oh great the winter
soldier a nod to bucky barnes from the
mcu unfortunately sonic drops his power
rings off the side of a snowy cliff and
they fall in the same way that they
would if he had gotten hit and lost his
rings in the game knuckles and robotnik
managed to get the compass away from him
and a giant avalanche begins right
before they fly away unable to portal
away from the snowpocalypse without his
rings sonic calls tom in a panic to ask
him for help getting out of there when
his phone goes off during randall and
rachel's wedding ceremony his ringtone
is the green hill zone theme from the
first level of the original classic game
[Music]
so help me thomas sorry tom opens a
portal and the entire wedding party and
all of their guests in hawaii are
showered in a flurry of snow that's when
it's revealed that randall isn't just
some guy that maddy's sister is marrying
he's actually an undercover agent sent
to spy on tom maddie and sonic from gun
gun is short for the guardian units of
nations and is essentially the
international military organization
tasked with protecting the earth in the
sonic lore but to the lykowski family's
total surprise the guy from the olive
garden in the first movie is actually
the head of gun commander walters i'm
not gonna lie rachel is pissed and not
just because her entire relationship was
a lie the woman who waxed her vajayjay
before the big day was apparently in on
the con too meanwhile robotnik and
knuckles followed the compass to an
island that holds the entrance to the
underwater temple where the emerald is
hidden the emerald emits a blast strong
enough to part the seas like moses
revealing a path that will lead them
straight to the gems hundreds of miles
away the wakowski family notices the
light emanating from the ocean and sonic
sets off running across the sea this is
a tall order for this little blue
hedgehog because baby boy can't swim to
psych himself up sonic says his
signature catch phrase before he starts
gotta go fast as knuckles and robotnik
race through the emerald temple they
face a series of indiana jones-esque
traps along their way towards the gem
this entire scene feels exactly like the
labyrinth zone from 1991 sonic the
hedgehog and temple of doom had a baby
during the fight between sonic and
knuckles over the emerald sonic dodges
knuckles punches just like he does in
the sonic x anime and the way he zips
around the temple during the fight is
similar to the anime as well the song
that plays while they're fighting is i
shrink therefore i am by christoph beck
and tyler lawson western which was
originally composed for marvel's ant-man
and the wasp
[Music]
hang on
[Applause]
unfortunately robotnik uses their brawl
as an opportunity to steal the emerald
for himself the temple collapses and
knuckles is trapped beneath a column as
the ocean around them begins to seep in
despite not being able to swim sonic
dives in to save him sucking in air
bubbles he passes for some extra oxygen
and homage to each of the underwater
levels in the game where you have to do
the same to keep sonic swimming back at
mean bean robotnik shows up full of the
power of the master emerald his coat is
now black with electrifying green
accents and he sounds like he's been
auto-tuned outside gun is stationed
ready to fight the helicopter that
brings commander walters to the scene is
marked with sa2 a reference to sonic
avengers 2. robotnik uses his powers to
disassemble all of the machinery in town
including guns weapons vehicles and
tactical gear his electric currents
magnetically swoop all of the pieces
into a tornado of whirling parts where
he begins to build his next weapon a
gigantic robotic robotnik kaiju that
wade excitedly exclaims is just like the
stavepuff marshmallow man as he
predicted as robotnik fires up the robot
the song he plays on leg guitar is
walked by pantera after rescuing sonic
and knuckles tails flies them in via an
airplane she stole from rachel and
randall's wedding knuckles decides to
attack them from the ground while the
other two stay in the air tails is
piloting the tornado sonic's red and
white biplane from the games normally
the plane belongs to sonic and he allows
tails to use it as his own and tails
usually flies the plane when they're
traveling long distances with sonic
riding on top robotnik knocks tails his
airplane out of the sky using the
mustache on his robot when he asks stone
how he did that joan whips out a user
manual that looks exactly like the sega
genesis user manual sonic knuckles and
tails decide to attack them together
with sonic acting as a distraction so
that knuckles and tails can strike
unexpectedly while tails annoys eggman
with his doppelgangers knuckles gut
punches the emerald right out of him the
way that he does this is just like the
way he punches the chaos emeralds out of
sonic and sonic the hedgehog 3 and
knuckles when sonic inspects the master
emerald it suddenly crumbles into the
chaos emeralds in his hands just as
robotnik is about to squish the wakowski
family the chaos emeralds activate and
sonic transforms into a powerful fiery
wielder of the emeralds when he
confronts robotnik the eggman tries to
weasel his way out of it by saying there
were good people on both sides just like
president trump did victorious sonic's
first order of business as a golden god
is to summon a few of his favorite chili
dogs that golden god line is a reference
to the scene and almost famous where
russell hammond drops acid and jumps off
the roof into a pool i am a golden god
knuckles sonic and tails take a solemn
vow to start a new order to protect the
emerald and the universe from any future
threats they seal their promise with a
power bump and head off to play baseball
if you recall from the first movie when
sonic first came to earth he hid while
watching some kids play a game of
baseball too afraid to join them later
that night he decides to play all the
positions on the field by himself now
sonic has two brand new pals to play
with in addition to his loving adoptive
parents sonic calls tom dad for the
first time i'm not gonna lie all i
almost cried as he announces tales on
the pitching mound while randy newman's
take me out to the ball game plays in
the background sonic refers to him by
his full name for the first time miles
tales prower and when knuckles scores a
game ending home run maddie offers to
take them out for ice cream of course
knuckles responds by asking if dessert
on earth has any grapes in it because
grapes are his favorite food in the
games as the 8-bit animated credits roll
the song that kid cudi wrote for the
film stars in the sky begins to play it
also briefly played while sonic was
running home at the beginning of the
movie the mid-credits scene shows guns
searching for robotnik agent stone is
apparently hiding in their ranks helping
to find his old boss one of gun's
employees finds a 59 year old file in a
secret research facility called project
shadow and we see the outline of a red
and black hedgehog floating in a water
tank this is of course shadow who i
mentioned earlier in the video when i
was talking about sonic's pose against
the moon from 2005's shadow the hedgehog
game introduced in 2001 in sonic
adventure 2 shadow is sonic's dark
gritty doppelganger rival he was
genetically engineered to be immortal by
robotnik's grandfather to help cure his
granddaughter maria of a terminal
illness he was unable to heal her but
they formed a close relationship and
shadow was heartbroken when gun showed
up to arrest dr robotnik the elder and
killed maria in the process gun
imprisons shadow and cryostasis until
eggman breaks him free from their prison
50 years later my guess is that this is
how sonic 3 will kick off with shadow
teaming up with robotnik to deliver some
hardcore attacks on sonic unlike tails
knuckles and even robotnik shadow
actually uses heavy artillery like guns
and other combat weapons so the gang is
going to have to majorly step up their
defenses shadow's trademark move is
chaos control and i'm sure that we'll
see him use his powers against sonic and
the chaos emeralds in the next movie
follow me on instagram and twitter
whitney puppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you